Lawmakers have reached a deal
to avoid another
government shutdown,
but President Trump says
he's not happy with it.
For more on this,
it's time for "A Closer Look."
♪♪
If there's one thing
we've learned about Donald Trump
in the two years
he's been president,
it's that you can't negotiate
with him,
which is ironic considering
that was his whole thing
he was supposed to be --
a great dealmaker who could
bring everyone together.
Although,
even during the campaign,
there were hints
that he didn't really know
what he was talking about.
-With Congress, you have to get
everybody in a room,
and you have to
get them to agree,
but you have to get them
to agree what you want,
and that's part
of being a dealmaker.
You have to get people in,
grab them, hug them, kiss them,
and get the deal done,
but it's got to be the deal
that you want.
-What are you talking about?
I mean, we all know you didn't
write "The Art of the Deal,"
but did you not even read it?
I mean, I'm just imagining
Trump chasing Chuck Schumer
around the Oval Office
trying to hug him.
"Come here, Chuck!
We got to make a deal, Chuck!"
[ Applause ]
Now...
if Trump kissed Mitch McConnell,
on the other hand,
he might finally
turn into a prince.
[ Laughter ]
Also, what you're describing
is not a deal.
What you're describing
is a Benny Hill sketch...
which is, I guess, why
you have the same hair.
This keeps happening.
For two years,
Trump has said in public
that he wants to make a deal,
but then, in reality,
he has neither the ability
to negotiate, nor the interest.
For example, you might remember
that after Trump unilaterally
subjected the country
to the longest government
shutdown in history,
forcing workers to go
without paychecks,
he claimed the one thing
he had gotten in his deal
with the Democrats
was an agreement
to negotiate over the wall,
although, as usual,
he was very hung up
on what words we should use
to describe the wall.
-I have seen and heard from
enough Democrats and Republicans
that they are willing
to put partisanship aside.
They have said they are for
complete border security,
and they have finally
and fully acknowledged
that having barriers,
fencing, or walls,
or whatever
you want to call it...
-How can you negotiate
for something
when you don't even know
what it is?
You know, people say Trump
doesn't work very hard,
but he's clearly spent a lot
of time sitting in his office,
typing the word "wall"
into a thesaurus.
"Call it whatever you want.
Barriers, fencing...
fortifications...
enclosures...
parapets."
So, that was Trump's big
announcement after the shutdown,
that lawmakers from both sides
would get together
and come up with a deal
that would avoid
another government shutdown
by the end of the week.
So how's that going?
Well, on Monday night,
Trump was asked for an update
on the negotiations
during an interview on Fox News
and said he wasn't
following the negotiations
because he was spending his time
doing interviews on Fox News.
-Mr. President, word broke
late today, early this evening
that there might be
some tentative deal struck
to avert a government shutdown.
What can you tell us?
-Well, I can tell you that
a lot of things have changed,
and we'll see what happens.
I can't go into the exact deal.
I just heard it very quickly,
coming over to see you.
It was between the deal and you,
and I had to choose you.
-He literally said,
"I had a choice between
running the government
and going on Fox News,
and I chose Fox News."
No quote has ever summed up
Trump's presidency
better than that.
Also, anyone can
get on Fox News.
It's not some exclusive
high-end night club.
Last week, they put this guy
on TV to talk about healthcare.
-I have eternal healthcare,
and it's free.
Doctors can give you
a little temporary reprieve,
but they cannot save you
from physical death.
The doctors who treat you,
they die, too.
-That guy wasn't even
in New York.
They just brought a camera
to his shack in the woods.
So, Trump made a big show of
championing the bipartisan talks
after he caved
in the shutdown fight,
and now he says he's not even
paying attention to them,
which might explain why
when he found out that the deal
didn't have any money for a
concrete border wall yesterday,
he said he wasn't happy with it.
Although, he didn't even
really seem to know
what he wanted
or what he was upset about.
-Sir, will you sign
Congress' border deal?
-I have to study it.
I'm not happy about it.
It's not doing the trick,
but I'm adding things to it,
and when you add
whatever I have to add,
it's all going to happen.
-He has all the specificity
of a "Real Housewives" promo.
"When you add whatever I have to
add, it's all going to happen."
[ Applause ]
I mean, I hope he's never
the only eyewitness to a crime.
"Yeah, it was a person somewhere
between 3 and 10 feet tall.
Two legs. Oh, and clothes!
He had clothes on. Or she."
Trump talks about the wall
like he just ran into one.
[ Laughter ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
Every few months --
Every few months,
we have to go through
this exhausting ritual
where we pretend the President
actually knows
what he's talking about, even
though it's clear he doesn't.
The negotiations over the wall
are just like the negotiations
over healthcare in 2017
when Trump kept saying
he wanted Democrats
to work with him
on the GOP healthcare bill
but also made clear
he had no idea
what was in the
GOP healthcare bill.
-We had to go with
the healthcare first,
and we're doing well.
I think we're going to have
some great surprises.
We are looking at a healthcare
that would be a fantastic
tribute to our country,
a healthcare that will
take care of people finally
for the right reasons
and also at the right cost.
This will be a plan where
you can choose your doctor.
This will be a plan
where you can choose your plan,
and you know what the plan is.
This is the plan.
"I call it...
the plan, plan, plan."
Every time he talks
about something complicated,
it's like an episode
of "Seinfeld"
where George is trying
to get fired.
"I have a plan, Jerry!"
"What's the plan?"
"It's a plan where
you can choose your plan!"
"And you think you'll get away
with this plan?"
"That's the plan!"
"Well, that's a hell of a plan."
[ "Seinfeld" theme plays ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
Yesterday, Trump tried to argue
that the wall was already
being built, which is not true.
And he even claimed he was
making old sections of the wall
look beautiful
by repainting them.
-We're getting
a beautiful-looking structure,
because it was crazy
what they were putting up.
In fact, I happen to think
that the walls
that they were building were
so unattractive and so ugly,
that walls got bad names, okay,
if that means anything.
-No, it doesn't.
It doesn't mean anything to us.
Walls didn't have bad names.
Walls had no names.
Before you showed up, we never
talked about walls at all.
And we certainly
never chanted about them.
Trump then continued to insist
that the wall was being built
while simultaneously complaining
that he was mad that Congress
wasn't giving him money
to build the wall.
And it was impossible to follow.
See if you understand
what he is talking about here.
-I can tell that you that --
Am I happy at first glance?
I just got to see it.
The answer is, no, I'm not.
I'm not happy.
But am I happy with where
we're going? I'm thrilled.
Because we're
supplementing things
and moving things around,
and we're doing things
that are fantastic.
-In the span of 20 seconds,
he went from saying
he was not happy
to saying he was thrilled
to saying he was doing things
that are fantastic.
If we just let him keep talking,
he'll say he's building
the wall, he built the wall,
everyone loves the wall,
and he's moving
to the southern border
to live in a one-bedroom
apartment with his
best friend, The Wall.
We're going to film it
for a TV show and call it
"Wall and Grace."
[ Cheers and applause ]
We are in this situation because
Trump sold his supporters
an obvious lie he had
no intention of keeping,
and now he's desperately trying
to save face.
For example, now he's just lying
and saying the wall
is already getting built.
In fact, he even said recently
that his supporters should start
chanting "finish the wall"
rather than "build the wall."
But judging from his rally
in Texas on Monday,
his supporters didn't
exactly hear the news.
-We're building the wall.
A lot of it has --
I mean, the chant now
should be "finish the wall"
as opposed to "build the wall."
'Cause we're building
a lot of wall.
-Build that wall!
Build that wall!
-Even your supporters know that
you haven't started the wall.
Because they know, if you had,
Fox News would have a camera
pointed at it 24/7,
and the foreman on the job would
be the fourth Fox and Friend.
[ Laughter ]
In fact, after that chant --
after that chant,
Trump tried to tell the crowd
that they were wrong.
-You really mean
"finish that wall,"
because we've built a lot of it.
It's "finish that wall."
-He's like the world's
[bleep] hypnotist.
"You're a chicken."
"What are you talking about?"
"Stop talking.
Chickens don't talk."
This is the lesson
of Trump's presidency so far.
You can't negotiate with someone
who inhabits a different reality
than you do.
Trump spends all day
digesting lies from Fox News.
Fox News, in turn, reinforces
his alternate reality.
In fact, Fox News
has been insisting for weeks
that even though Trump didn't
get any money for his wall,
in the end
he'll find a way to win.
-Anyone out there, by the way,
thinking President Trump
caved today,
you don't really know
the Donald Trump I know.
He right now holds
all the cards.
-I think the President's
probably going to say,
"You know what? I'm going to
take that number right there.
$1.4 billion
for 55 miles of border wall."
And then I bet he's got
something up his sleeve.
-If Trump ever has anything
up his sleeve,
it's a cheeseburger
that somehow got stuck there.
He just hasn't found it yet.
"What the hell is --
Ohh! Hello, friend!"
Trump sold his voters
an obvious lie
that he had no intention
of keeping,
and now he's concocting
more lies to justify
the original lie.
He's never going to
get his wall.
He doesn't even have a plan
for getting his wall.
If you ask him to describe
his plan, he'd say...
-You know what the plan is.
This is the plan.
-This has been "A Closer Look."